Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron Cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today and tomorrow. Well,
we also have to talk you know, we've talked a
lot about Republican extremists. We've talked
January six, Donald Trump, all of that. We got
to get to some issues here, folks. And of course,
one of the biggest issues facing Americans today
is inflation. You know, whether it's gas prices or
goods services, everything out there, inflation is
absolutely crippling the United States economy.
And according to a new report from the Roosevelt
Institute. A lot of this, if inflation, if
you want to call it that, is actually rooted
in nothing more than corporate greed. Now, that's
not to say that inflation is not happening right
now at a staggering and alarming rate. It
is, but it's happening all over the world,
not just here in the United States. This is not
a U.S. problem. This is a global supply issue.
But here in the United States, we do have
something a little bit unique. We have what is
being called now greed flirtation. And that greed
flirtation is corporations, of course, jacking
up prices beyond what inflation is, forcing
them to pay and passing that on to consumers.
It's a very simple scam. And to be honest,
corporations, many CEOs, executives, they've
actually admitted to doing this in interviews
over the past year. They have said on the record
that times of high inflation are the perfect
time for companies to raise their prices
anyway. One because they don't get blamed for it.
But two, inflation eventually goes away. You know,
sometimes it lasts a little longer, you know, but
eventually the prices will go back down. And when
people start seeing the price tags go back down,
they get happy, too, like, oh, boy, it's over. And
then eventually the price will settle somewhere.
That will be more than what it was before the
period of inflation, but lower than what it was
with inflation. So consumers think they win.
But that difference between the pre inflation
price and the post inflation price, that
is the corporate price gouging. And again,
this new report from the Roosevelt Institute
says that corporate price gouging right now
based on profits. Based on what they're paying
these corporations. With inflation and then
passing on to consumers is the worst level it
has been in the United States since the 19 1850s.
So it's been roughly 70 years. Most people alive
today. Have never seen corporate price gouging
as bad as it is. And of course, this was just for
the year 2021 because we don't have final numbers
from 2022 because we're only halfway through the
year. So this report was only looking at last year
when inflation and price gouging was not
as bad as it has been so far this year.
If you want to know a good example, look at
Tyson Foods. Tyson Foods recently released,
you know, their their quarterly report. In their
quarterly report. They showed that inflation had
caused their costs to go up. I'm just going to
make up numbers because I don't remember exactly,
but I do remember the percentages. So trust
me, let's say their costs went up 1.5 billion.
But the prices they raised for consumers
wasn't 1.5 billion. It was 2 billion.
So there's a $500 million gap in there
that is nothing more than corporate greed,
raising prices simply for the fact that they can.
And again, those weren't the exact numbers, but
it was the correct percentages. There was a 25%
increase. So what we're looking at is a
time when the United States, more than ever,
needs a windfall profit tax on these corporations,
whether it's the oil industry, whether
it's the grocery stores. Manufacturers, car
manufacturers done matter. A windfall profits tax
could put an end to this corporate price gouging
that is crushing Americans every time they go
shopping doesn't matter what they go shopping for.
And believe it or not, this corporate windfall
profit tax is now supported by a majority
of American citizens. A majority of them.
Want this windfall profits tax. It's a simple
solution. It's a simple solution to a growing
problem that affects the wallets of everybody in
this country, rich and poor alike. It obviously
affects the poor a lot more than it affects
the rich. But everybody's paying higher prices.
The windfall profits tax could put an end
to that. We just have to have legislators
with the courage to actually do this. And
unfortunately, we do not have enough of them.
Instead we get ideas from Biden, like coming out
this week, like, oh, what about a gas tax holiday?
Cool. You're going to save the average American
family $3.60 a week. Those are the numbers, folks.
3.60 cents a week is what you would probably
end up saving on average. The average family,
actually, if you fill up your tank once a week
and you got a 20 gallon tank. The $3.60 isn't
going to change your life at all. Honestly, it's
not even going to help you. I'm sorry, but it's
not. You can't even buy a gallon of milk with that
because of inflation and corporate price gouging.
So that's a bad idea, especially because that
money is actually used to fund infrastructure.
And hey, we're already having trouble spending our
infrastructure bill money because of inflation.
So all those infrastructure projects that
we were promised, they've been put on hold
because the prices are so dang high. We're just
getting screwed every which way you look at it.
And all of it comes right back
to that issue of corporate greed.